thank you thank you for the nice
introduction thank everyone for coming
just yeah it's it's great to see all the
excitement around around this area so
unfortunately maybe compared to what
people may be expecting I'm not going to
talk about why deep learning is great in
a lot of details I'm not going to spend
a lot of time talking about applications
I'm hopefully I'm hopeful that people
have maybe heard a little bit of enough
of that and I'd like to spend a lot of
the time during this talk focusing on a
clear opportunity for improving the
performance of deep learning I'm also
hoping to convince you that performance
actually matters for these workloads and
computers aren't even close to being
fast enough this is going to be a pretty
technical talk I'm gonna focus on a lot
of open research areas here where I
don't think anybody knows the answer to
to these questions so I'm gonna pose
some questions as we go along here and
I'm hoping that some of the work that
people are doing here
can help make progress on some of these
problems I'm gonna try to convince you
that if we do make progress the result
will be worth it okay so let's I'm going
to start by briefly summarizing the
success in deep learning this year and
I'm gonna focus on two results so the
first result I guess it's on on your on
your left is the progress made in image
recognition so this is plotting accuracy
on the image net benchmark challenge
over here over years so in 2011 we would
think of as the first time the deep
learning algorithms were really applied
to this problem and you can just see
this very steady improvement in
performance over time after that point
the other tech the other technology that
I'd like to focus on is speech
recognition this is work that we did it
by do research this is shown on on the
other side of the figure we're looking
at a single deep recurrent neural
network that's performing a task of
speech recognition so it's converting
from
audio data into a textural
representation
there's practicum ponents in the system
other than the deep neural network I'll
talk about this in a little bit more
detail but in two languages with the
same algorithm so in English and in
Mandarin were able to approach human
level performance where human level
performance is measured by querying or
tasking a number of humans to listen to
audio and write down what they think the
answer is having them even debate you
know it with a small group of people to
form a consensus and comparing the
result of that against the result of the
system and we actually match the
performance in in Mandarin in many
situations and it's right so the idea
here is that these are really examples
people may think that deep learning
really applies well to vision problems
and it may be hard to think of problems
outside of vision as being accessible to
deep learning I think that the deep
speech work is actually important
because it shows that deep learning can
be applied to other problem domains as
well so we are applying it here to
speech recognition there have been
recent successes also in natural
language processing and reinforcement
learning so the recent result that
people may have may have heard of is the
a single or a deeper or a deep neural
network playing the game of go and
beating the world champion this is work
done by google's deepmind group and so
there's just examples of deep learning
starting out in vision and being applied
successfully to other domains as well so
we see this trend continuing into the
future and let's so so there's one maybe
main reason why why this is being driven
for there's one main cause that's
actually creating this opportunity so
I'm going to focus on that a little bit
I'm gonna focus on if by examining the
deep speech to system in a little bit
more detail so this figure really tries
to show how the algorithm works in terms
of the basic building blocks
so on one side we have an input audio
waveform in the middle we have a deep
convolutional recurrent neural network
we have a CTC cost function this is just
a minor detail just think of this as an
error function that's grading the
network in terms of how good the
prediction is compared to a reference
these are trained in supervised learning
settings so we have a large data set a
lot of audio clips we have a lot of
reference labels and we're making small
updates to the network to try to match
match the reference labels so one thing
that's really important to realize here
is if you look at the network
architectures between the algorithm
that's used for english recognition and
the algorithm that's used for Mandarin
recognition the only thing that changes
is the output character set so in the
first case for outputting English
characters in the second case for
outputting Mandarin characters directly
it's a much larger set of characters in
Chinese it's more not more like 30 it's
more like 5,000 10,000 50,000 if you if
you want to include absolutely
everything but most people usually don't
use the complete set
so with basically the same algorithm
it's a very major change to think about
just changing the output set we can
approach human level accuracy with the
same algorithm but there's a wrinkle
here these networks are extremely
expensive to train so one rule of thumb
that we have is basically right so one
rule of thumb that we have is we're
going to train these systems on the
biggest fastest computer that we have
and we're gonna do it you know not for
any specific amount of time we're gonna
do it up to the point where we're you
know we get bored or we get impatient
and this is usually about two two weeks
to about a month and after that if your
experiment starts taking maybe a year
two years you start wondering you know
is there something better that I can do
with my time
so the 20x of flops of work kind of
translates into about two weeks or about
a month on a very high-end high
throughput optimized system so let's
look at that all right so that that kind
of
it's getting towards this motivation
where we just need we need faster or we
need more performance I want to look at
that just in one more detail here this
is the absolute most important result
for deep learning this is why deep
learning works so you know perhaps in
the past you may have seen a graph like
this that's actually kind of a cartoon
graph that's just trying to show a
relationship or on one axis we have the
data set size and on the other axis we
either have an accuracy or an error rate
on a proton a problem so this is looking
at the deep speech model in this example
this is a real graph this is real data
so we see a power law relationship
between the dataset size and the
accuracy right this is the reason why we
care about compute large internet
companies basically have infinite data
10,000 hours of data is super tiny it is
it is minuscule compared to the scale of
data that's available on the Internet
it's also you also may wonder well maybe
that's true for unlabeled data but what
about labeled data isn't it really
expensive to get labeled data this is
just a money problem it's not actually
very expensive in an absolute sense in
compared to the scale of computer that
you have to run this on especially to
gather a data set of this size the
reason why this graph doesn't keep
extending to the right is because we
don't know how to map these algorithms
on to even bigger computers so this is
the promise of deep learning does this
hold up on other application domains and
does this graph continue off to the
right with larger data sets so we hope
it does we also believe that there's an
opportunity to improve performance deep
learning has been one maybe one of the
first drivers major drivers of using
high performance processors like GPUs
high throughput processors like GPUs to
accelerate model training or to
accelerate this workload it took a lot
of work actually to port these
algorithms on the GPUs
GPUs are notoriously hard to program
there's a lot of parallelism it's really
there's a lot of complexity there's a
lot of latency it's hard to get good
throughput out of them for many
algorithms this is not an easy problem
at all deep learning is relatively easy
from that perspective it's very regular
it's very much aligned with traditional
HPC workloads like big dense linear
algebra problems and so the state of the
art right now is running deep learning
training algorithms on one or a few GPUs
but there's a huge gap between one and a
few GPUs or a few GPUs and the biggest
supercomputer that we could think of
building so this graph tries to show a
tight next GPU which is a relatively
high end GPU from Nvidia as a green data
point here and the gap between that
single GPU and the largest publicly
available or publicly released
supercomputer in the world is about
10,000 times so there's a huge
opportunity to push the performance of
deep learning training forward and to
take advantage of larger datasets
hopefully unlocking even better accuracy
even better or even lower error rates on
hard problems and artificial
intelligence like speech recognition
vision decision-making natural language
okay there's a go ahead no not at all
this you know the the points up here
have 10,000 20,000 GPUs in them or other
high performance processors I'd also
like to point out that the top 500
supercomputers is the publicly available
list that this data is based off of
there are definitely faster computers
than this in the world this isn't the
public list
there's at least I would guess there's
maybe one or two more or as a magnitude
in here okay so I tried to draw a little
cartoon that describes what model
training looks like so you know we have
this huge opportunity to improve
performance we have this workload we
really like to accelerate the first step
is probably developing a better
understanding of that workload so this
is a cartoon representation that tries
to capture the major components of deep
learning model training so the top we
have a training data set the size of
these data sets varies by application
usually because we're compute limited
this isn't as big of a data set as you
might find in other domains
this isn't ten 10 petabytes of data this
is maybe a couple terabytes of data it
depends on the representation so images
would be different than speech would be
different than language it kind of goes
in the order of languages the most
compressed speech is the next most
compressed and images of the least
compressed so this is hours of audio so
just in terms of some concrete numbers
I think 10,000 hours of audio here is in
the range of one to ten terabyte again
it depends on the application usually so
you see this power law relationship
right so you would need so the way to
think about this perhaps in the context
of speech is if we went from 10
terabytes to a hundred terabytes we'd
get something like a 30 or 40 percent
reduction in error rate so you do need a
larger and larger data set to get to get
better performance
sort of hidden a slight imbalance
between the need or cycles to the amount
of storage you really need more cycles
to storage yes especially compared to
other application a sort of doctors
definition of what constitutes a
supercomputer where terms of computing
about problems of an IO bowel problem
you heard that right
so I don't think we're there I don't
think I don't think this workload is is
actually becoming i/o bound I'll cover
that a little bit more detail there
there's some subtleties Harwich what if
you take 10,000 hours multiply that
obviously buy us some sampling rate to
get some some some amount of storage and
you're talking about terabytes but
that's like six orders of magnitude
exabytes yeah right so people you jumped
over oh sorry
when I when I mentioned exa here I meant
I meant flops not bytes made this cool
other walkies he basically said for
every myth intended me to megabyte and
you need a megabyte per second this
little syrup triangle it's in this paper
so you don't have a sense of how much
storage you're actually gonna need for
this 20 X of X of locks it's much less
it's much less it's a different kind of
relationship instead of lightweight
compute and very heavyweight storage you
have an inverse relationship you have
very heavyweight compute very
lightweight storage capacity
requirements right it's it's something
that's fundamentally different about
these workloads the access pattern is
also a little bit strange so here I have
this as a shuffle operation here so you
have your 10 terabytes data set it's
broken out into possibly millions of
into
training samples they may be a very you
know different sizes we'll cover that a
little bit later and you're randomly
accessing it so the common algorithm
that you use to train these models is
called stochastic gradient descent the
stochastic component means you want to
traverse the data set in a random order
this is actually part of the part of why
the algorithm works of course there are
a lot of details there but this is this
is really what people use in practice
there are a lot of alternatives but this
is the thing that people commonly use in
practice so you end up with this random
traversal over the data set and you end
up gathering a number of training
samples you process these in parallel
this is one of the main sources of
parallelism that you get this is called
data parallelism in machine learning
terminology which is different than the
common usage of data parallelism in
high-performance computing terminology
data parallelism here means that you're
running the same neural network model
over different samples drawn out of your
data set okay so internally in the model
because big multi-layer convolutional
and recurrent neural networks they
involve a lot of dense linear algebra
operations there's a lot of inherent
parallelism in those operations so this
is what we call model parallelism
because parallelism that is inherent in
the evaluation of the model in terms of
the workload you usually have a forward
and backward operation so the forward
operation evaluates the network the
backward operation computes gradients
with respect to the model parameters
they're usually the way that these
networks are designed these operations
are about equal in terms of the amount
of compute performed they're actually
very efficient now if you think about a
lot of other problems where you can't
compute gradients analytically may be
much more expensive to do this type of
thing but with neural networks just
because of the way that they're
constructed this operation is extremely
efficient okay so let's see so the way
that you train your model is
you traverse your data set in this
random order you gather mini-batches you
perform forward backward propagation you
compute a gradient you take a step and
then you repeat the process until you've
cycled through your data set a number of
times it's really important to realize
one aspect of this that's that's maybe
that may not really be apparent the
first time you look at it this algorithm
is amazingly work efficient so what do I
mean by work efficient I mean if you
think about all of the different
algorithms you could use to modify the
weights of them of a model like this and
find a good solution and you think about
the amount of computation implied by
these different algorithms this
algorithm implies about 20 accesses to
every point in your data set so what
does that mean so it means that you kind
of look at every example in your data
set maybe 10 or 20 times you do the
amount of work implied by the model
parameters which is just you know linear
in the number of parameters in the model
and you can actually find a good
solution to many hard problems like
vision or speech recognition it's really
amazing that this works as effectively
as it does I'm not gonna say anything
about why that is I have no idea why
that is but it's a really amazing effect
ok so one thing that people also may not
realize here from a computational
perspective is that because we're using
the stochastic gradient descent we have
a sequential dependence between steps or
between iterations this is one of the
main difficulties in scaling this type
of approach on larger machines is that
really you just run out of parallelism
there's a lot of parallelism in here but
not enough for a giant machine ok so
given these characteristics the next
question is clearly you know how do we
exploit this parallelism how do we
exploit the characteristics of this
workload to get better performance on
real systems so I want to start this
conversation by focusing
on the pitfalls because I think that
they're a few issues here that aren't
really very obvious that people commonly
fall into and you know as a researcher
working in this area we have to be very
mindful of these issues so that we can
actually solve a real problem that's
actually you know makes progress on
accelerating training and not just
convince or fools us into thinking that
we are so this is the first one so
beware of ignoring work efficiency so
what does this mean many optimizations
may trade work efficiency for throughput
so what do I mean by this if we go back
to the previous idea of the how the
workload is actually structured you can
it's very easy oftentimes to basically
get a higher throughput on a machine so
get more parallelism running a we're not
a higher throughput you know process
your data set faster but at the same
time increase the total amount of work
that you have to do in order to reach
the same result so this is just one
effect that I wanted to focus on that's
a really common pitfall here so this is
the effect of increasing the mini batch
size which is the number of samples that
you use to estimate your gradient as you
increase this to a point it doesn't
really matter the idea is that getting a
better estimate of the gradient is
actually useful to some extent because
it reduces noise but you don't want it
to be too big if you make it too big
like let's imagine we made it comically
big like making it the entire data set
size do you imagine that having a really
accurate estimate of a gradient would
allow you to make very fast progress in
a hundred million dimension space you
really think that one step you know or
20 steps in a hundred million dimension
space can do as well as millions or
billions of smaller steps so usually
this is the effect that you see you can
increase the mini batch size to some
point and you maintain a constant amount
of computational work and after some
point which is problem dependent it
usually increases
and you're trading basically better
throughput more parallelism for doing
more work which actually isn't getting
you anywhere okay so let's see my friend
Brian Catanzaro I was always always
interested or always you know good at
making this point there's no lower bound
on how bad a baseline can be okay so one
thing that we're one common trick that
we're doing here is we're looking at all
the parallelism available in our
application and we're saying can we
spread this out on more machines right
and if we do this effectively we can get
better scaling or better throughput if
we compare the performance on one
machine against the performance on 10 or
100 machines if we're doing a good job
we can usually see increased performance
with more with more computational
resources but this is only true if your
baseline is good if your performance on
a single machine is any good at all
and it's sometimes hard to say what is
good if you're starting from an
implementation that you don't understand
very well or you're looking at a result
in literature that is reporting
something like the time you know in an
absolute sense it's very hard to say how
efficient that implementation actually
is so there's this very nice framework
at commonly used it in video that's
called this concept of a speed of light
of an algorithm or a speed of light of
of hardware and the idea here is that
there's a fundamental limit based on the
hardware platform that you have based on
the physical assumptions that were used
to design that hardware platform what is
the best possible performance that you
can do and so the point is don't measure
yourself against an arbitrary
implementation that you have no idea how
efficient it is measure measure yourself
against the best that you can do so the
best that you can do is the theoretical
maximum performance on the processor
that you're running on so you know this
cartoon here we're showing you know you
can slow down an application arbitrarily
by adding in you know hundreds of layers
of abstraction and it makes
really easy to show good scalability but
this isn't really very useful to anybody
so try to measure yourself against the
maximum possible performance possible
and not any baseline just ignore the
baselines don't even don't even compare
against them against them okay so I
wanted to spend some time going through
a bunch of technologies that have been
applied to improving performance on this
time type of workload that already work
that are used in practice I just want to
spend some time trying to establish what
the state of the art actually is okay so
one clear trend is dense compute
hardware so there's a clear trend
towards building the highest throughput
processors possible which are currently
currently GPUs although I hate using the
word GPU because they're really just
parallel processors there are a lot of
other parallel processors that are very
efficient that aren't called GPUs I'm
just gonna I'm going to stick with GPUs
right now because maybe it's a common
terminology but really just densest
highest throughput parallel processor
that you can think of so the concept of
density is extending to the node
architecture so this is showing to know
configurations that we use it by do one
is a dual CPU configuration we use a
four-way pci switch each switch hosts
four GPUs so these are all in one for
you box this puts it at about a three
three kilowatt box we also have a we
also have an even denser machine where
this really just pushes the limits of
physical integration we have sixteen
GPUs in one four-year box this is more
like a five six kilowatt box there is a
clear trend in here which is kind of
interesting which is we end up just
spending all of our resources all of our
money on GPUs and we're basically just
using the CPU here to run a driver and
to access the data set and orchestrate
the network communications but the
reason why we're doing all of this
is there's a realization that data
movement is expensive
the further you have to move data
physically the more energy you have to
pay to do that so we're trying to put
the densest possible processors as close
together as possible so this is a clear
trend all right
another clear trend is to focus on fast
tightly coupled network interfaces fast
interconnects so this is something
that's already a clear trend in
high-performance computing if you look
at how modern Internet data centers are
configured this is not how they're
configured at all there are some you
know cost issues associated with this
like how much money do you really want
to spend on your network there's also
technology and software stack issues
here but for deep learning because we
actually that there's actually this huge
benefit of having dense compute in order
to expand beyond what you can fit into a
single box you have to worry about the
interconnect and so we have to we have
to spend a lot of resources using using
faster interconnects so we would use
something like 50 to 100 gigabit per
second InfiniBand or Ethernet links
between boxes
we'd also use MPI so why do we use MPI
rather than you know some more flexible
communication protocol MPI is just
really well optimized on these types of
hardware platforms it's actually hard to
get the maximum bandwidth possible out
of an interconnect with just
off-the-shelf software if you try just
running you know even something like IP
over InfiniBand you typically see you
know 2x or more slowdown layering on
more levels of abstraction typically
reduces performance at these speeds as
well we we use MPI really not not for
any other reason than the software as
well optimized for high performance on
these interconnects also the
characteristics these workloads are a
little bit different than what you would
normally use MPI for so MPI
very highly optimized around small
messages so a lot there is really
sensitive to latency there's this
concept in high-performance computer
computing called strong scaling where
you really care about the latency units
of works gets small and so they finish
quickly and so you if you take too long
in terms of latency in your interconnect
you can end up being limited by that and
so there's a lot of optimizations around
latency reduction those are actually not
the right thing to do for deep learning
training we have giant models a common
operation that we do with their giant
models is that we synchronize them over
a lot of different machines this is just
a lot of parallel bandwidth intensive
data transfer going on here and so the
default algorithms that MPI uses for
exchanging data in an operation called
an all reduce are tuned for latency and
not bandwidth so there are algorithms
like ring algorithms that are more work
efficient in terms of the total amount
of data that they send over the network
and so by moving to these algorithms we
can see very significant speed ups so
faster interconnects care a lot about
the total amount of data moved over the
network this is a clear trend as well
go ahead yes rapira yeah fault tolerance
here it's a really good question I'll
get I'll get into it a little bit in
more more detail in a minute but yeah
the state of the artist checkpointing
models run for weeks you know they're so
so the overhead of checkpointing
somewhat infrequently isn't too bad yeah
I'll talk about this a little bit
there's a really weird effect that comes
in here that's based on the robustness
of these models to to small errors these
models are actually very robust to small
errors so we'll get into that in a
minute
go ahead
you see I treat yes oh you consider
let's see so in terms of off-the-shelf
hardware that you can buy easily it's
hard to get direct direct links you can
you can do our DMA typically over PCI
switches it turns out that we're
actually you know it with this kind of
effect we're in a more bandwidth
sensitive regime than a latency
sensitive regime our DMA really helps
you a lot more in a latency sensitive
regime so it hasn't become too much of
an issue yet I feel like going forward
there are huge advantages in terms of
being able to build higher bandwidth
interconnects and reducing the energy
consumption and interconnects from
tighter integration and more direct
links really I view this as being a
problem just with the hardware
technology because this hasn't people
haven't been aware of the need for
faster and lower or higher bandwidth
interconnects people haven't built these
these links yet yes that's true so
different yeah I would say the most
common data access pattern right now is
this ring algorithm so you end up having
GPUs communicating with their nearest
neighbor sending like very large data
transfers very bandwidth sensitive data
transfers over individual links so you
can orchestrate it over a tree like this
clearly if you have a tree we're not you
know this isn't the most efficient use
of all of our routing resources
yes that's what you're ideally want to
do it's it one thing that's very
important is keeping in mind the
placement of individual GPUs so to worry
about the physical placement not just
the logical placement so if you're doing
one of these ring algorithms you do not
want to be for example hopping all the
way across your system when individuai
of nodes are communicating so it's very
important to have some information about
the physical topology of your network
and to really understand for the system
that you're running on what is the
physical network topology does that make
sense
okay okay so great so one solution to
basically reducing the amount of or
improving the amount of time it takes to
do these data exchanges between models
mainly for data parallelism is just
building faster interconnects using
reduction algorithms that are highly
optimized there are other approaches
also that work at the algorithmic level
to try and reduce the total amount of
communication so for systems with weak
interconnects or less well optimized
interconnects its more common for this
to be a problem and for these techniques
to apply so there's three main sets of
techniques that are used here one is
called asynchronous stochastic gradient
descent one is called butterfly mixing
or butterfly STD and one is called
sparse or quantized SGD so I can kind of
go through these they all kind of work
to reduce the bandwidth requirements
they all they all introduced some kind
of concept of a delay or some kind of
concept of using stale information and
so because of this from an optimization
perspective they're always less
efficient the hope is is that the
trade-off is worth it that you can you
know be a little bit less efficient your
stale information is not hurting you too
much and the benefit that you get in
terms of latency tolerance or bandwidth
reduction gives you a large enough speed
up on your whole system that you can
overcome that that reduced efficiency so
asynchronous SGD is the most common
implementation here I want to make one
point about this that I don't think it's
really well known asynchronous SGD is
popular probably because it's very easy
to implement it's easy to implement
because you can just imagine taking a
bunch of nodes they're all trading
models simultaneously you can take
synchronous communication and just say
well send it asynchronously so the
receivers will receive it they'll apply
the updates whenever they get it and
that gives you a bunch of really nice
effects actually
so you do synchronization less often so
this reduces the total amount of
bandwidth you need it also gives you
latency tolerance so your updates can be
delayed you might see an update multiple
iterations later this is this gives you
more latency tolerance you also get a
nice effective load balancing so if
everybody is sending data to one
bottleneck dear the network protocols
will naturally apply back pressure the
rate will be slowed down and if one and
let's say for example if one model is
sending a lot more data to a
synchronization point or do a
centralized server and another one is
sending much less you get some kind of
natural balance of the bandwidth the one
that's sending a lot of data it may just
take longer for that data to actually be
sent so then it might send it at a less
frequency and so you get a natural load
balancing effect the biggest problem
with all of this is that you get non
determinism so the way I like to
describe this is that imagine that you
have a knob on your network and the knob
controls the clock speed of your network
of all of your network links so if I you
know as a malicious person can go over
and just turn that knob while your
algorithm is running and I increase the
clock speed maybe your model is working
just fine but now I can go and turn it
the other way and I can dial down the
clock speed and you as a user is like
looking at your algorithm watching your
training curve go down hopefully
converging to a better solution as I
turn down the clock speed low enough my
network can now stop converging I can
now get errors in my network and so with
real systems where interconnect
performance is very non-deterministic
you have dine out dynamic clock
frequency scaling going on
you have congestion you might have other
applications running on your network
this effect here is really dangerous for
reproducibility and for debugging so
imagine you have a model and you ran for
a month and it gets even a wonderful
result and now you want to reproduce
and you want to tweak it in some way or
you want to design an experiment we say
what happens if I add 10% more data and
I run the same experiment because of the
dynamic conditions in my network I might
end up with a worse result this might
lead me to a false conclusion
similarly if my network crashes for a
real software bug or a numerical
precision error and I try and restart it
to try and reproduce this error I may
never see it again because my training
is now non-deterministic so my main
point here is just that you can have
everything good here with removing all
the bad things here you can just add
delays and synchronize less frequently
and do explicit load balancing and you
can get all of the same effects with a
purely deterministic algorithm there's
no reason not to do this other than just
writing the code okay so let's see so
I'm just going to continue on through a
bunch of these different optimizations
and different technologies used in
practice so I want to mention one thing
about optimized kernels part of the
really nice effect of GPUs are the
really nice programming environment
around GPUs is that they're actually are
programmable
you can actually get in and edit the
source code of individual algorithmic
building blocks so I can go rewrite my
matrix multiply code or my convolution
code and I can swap out better
algorithms if I find them so using FFT
methods using Winograd methods for
convolutions result in better work
efficiency for convolutions so there's
been a significant amount of work that's
gone into this area that's actually made
the building blocks that the
higher-level networks will run on more
efficient so persistent are n ends are
another example of this this is some
work that we did at by do the main idea
here is just to realize that waits and
recurrent neural networks are constant
over multiple time steps a
straightforward way of implementing this
and the most common way of implementing
this is just using matrix multiply
operations
but those operations don't exploit the
fact that weights are constant so if you
actually realize that you can write a
custom matrix multiply implementation
that caches individual tiles throughout
the memory hierarchy of a GPU and avoid
the main cost which is loading the
weights over and over and over again ok
ok so I want to say there were some
questions before about the i/o
requirements of these systems so I
wanted to take just a moment to talk
about them kind of more explicitly so
this is the requirement for the deep
speech system and this is kind of maybe
a simplistic way of characterizing the
IR requirement we basically need for
every 25 teraflop sustained which is
maybe what we get on 8 GPUs we need
about a hundred megabytes per second of
random 16 kilobyte to 1 megabyte
accesses there's a distribution it's
kind of kind of normal over between a
minimum value of 16 kilobytes and a
maximum value of about 1 megabyte so
this is tough for a spinning disk to
keep up with and and over a very large
machine so over something like 30 or 40
compute nodes each with eight GPUs or 16
GPUs in them it actually adds up to be a
very significant amount of bandwidth and
it's random access bandwidth the data
set size is also not tiny its terabytes
so we essentially built a 40 terabyte I
Oh node that connects over InfiniBand it
delivers about 6 gigabytes per second of
64 K random reads as far as I know there
aren't off-the-shelf file systems or i/o
systems that can sustain these rates if
we were to add more nodes here or if we
were to significantly bump up the
performance of individual nodes this
would become an even bigger problem
we'd need even bigger total total memory
or total IO capacity and even more
random access bandwidth so it's not
killing a
yet but it's right on the edge this is
when you're building these mini batches
right that's primary data and so if you
just rated this out of it you just
have all your yourself your data across
a large number of disks then you could
pipeline that and avoid the problem and
scale up as long as you the total amount
of data per disk constantly yeah it's
just keep scaling and that would always
work yes absolutely I think that's I
think that's definitely right I think
it's not what we're doing here I think
for a few reasons
part of it might have just been legacy
like maybe the right solution here is
just to buy a big luster cluster or a
big gpfs cluster usually when we've
priced these things out if we actually
buy the amount of bandwidth and the
amount of i/o performance that we need
it ends up being multiple factors on top
of the cost of the compute nodes so we
might spend maybe a million dollars or
something for these compute nodes it
might cost us 10 million or 20 million
dollars to get a file system maybe
that's a solvable problem I'm not I'm
not sure the training data on the nodes
so that's an option I think it becomes
it's more viable with small data sets
all right so if you have a data set
that's much smaller than you know 40
terabytes then maybe you're fine if
you're around one terabyte or five
terabytes something like that but you
have this effect where as you get more
computing you really want to tap to
access more data and then arrange the
mini batches such that the compute nodes
are only pulling samples from data that
they have on board great so I think
they're just software problems with
doing that because imagine let's see
imagine that you're not always using the
whole cluster like imagine that you have
jobs of different sizes and shapes
running on this cluster it's very hard
to think about a replication pattern
that satisfies all of those constraints
other than replicating everything
everywhere
very fast if you could store your data
in the repository right okay so so the
question I guess is why do we store them
with a file system maybe with a POSIX
interface rather than some more
specialized storage like a key value
store or a block store we've definitely
looked at that I think the the
explanation here was really more of
really it was just an example the system
that we're actually using is a custom
system that doesn't the doesn't you have
present a POSIX interface we actually do
have a block based interface okay all
right so that's kind of what people are
doing today I wanted to spend a few
minutes talking about things that are
just to me at least and probably to
other people working this area these are
clear improvements that will obviously
work and nobody has implemented them yet
so these are the low-hanging fruit
all right this is a really big one this
is memory efficient back propagation
there is a paper by Alex graves and
others from from Google about this but
really so the main idea here is that
there's actually a lot of memory that
goes into back propagation storing
activations for back propagation the
common way that people implement this is
imagine that this line yes all right
so imagine that this line is the forward
propagation of the network and each of
these individual smaller solid lines
here represent evaluation of individual
operations or individual layers
and you kind of walk all the way from
the very beginning the inputs of the
network all the way to the end and in at
the intermediate points these solid
lines you save all of the the
activations or all of the at the edges
in the network that cross from one layer
into the next then on back propagation
you go you go the other way you do the
reverse operation and you use this
memory that's stored and it's actually
essential for computing gradients so
this is how you usually perform this
operation this okay so there's there's
an observation here which is that you
don't actually have to store any of this
you can recompute it and so you can
trade the memory storage that you're
using to save these activations against
extra computation being done and there's
you know many different ways many
different possible schedules of doing
this if it's if you have a fixed network
architecture you have a fixed memory
budget there's probably an optimal
solution to this problem that you can
set up and solve for explicitly there's
a really clever heuristic that does it
in a divide-and-conquer way that
essentially gives you it's basically
it's basically 30% more compute for
logarithmic storage of the activations
it's a very simple algorithm you can
apply it to any network this was
originally proposed for back propagation
through time
mainly because back propagation through
time kind of unrolls a network over many
time steps if you have a lot of time
steps this line here can get really long
and you can just end up saving a lot of
memory and so it's clear that you could
do it there and it would be beneficial
there but really this applies to
arbitrary graphs think of your neural
network unrolled over time as a directed
acyclic a cyclic computation graph this
technique can apply to any kind of
computation graph so just take the
critical path imagine it as a line
divide and conquer and you end up with a
logarithmic requirement for memory
rather than Oh N
so it's a huge benefit if you have a
hundred layers or you have a thousand
time steps so frameworks don't implement
this yet they really should as an
optimal solution yeah it will give you
the same answer a suit assuming that all
of the operations are deterministic
computer operations with memory i/o
operations which which way are you going
on the trade-off okay so the idea so
we're trait so the question is are we
treating compute operations for memory
operations to some extent that's true
what's more important actually is that
we're trading compute operations for
memory capacity so the memory capacity
especially in high speed memories like
the GPU gdg our memories or high
bandwidth memories is pretty small
actually so it's easy to be constrained
not by the total amount of compute that
you have but by the total amount of
memory required to store your model so
here we're doing more compute to need
less memory okay all right this is one
all right so I've got maybe one or two
more of these here just in terms of
timing is it 5:30 or 8:00 a.m.
camera stops but if you're not here okay
we can hear mm stops at 5:45 yeah all
right perfect okay so all right so this
was memory efficient backpropagation
the next one I want to talk about is
model parallelism model parallelism is
basically taking your big neural network
and realizing that there's a lot of
parallelism in the individual operations
that make up the network this graph on
on this side is trying to show you the
performance characteristics in terms of
the basic performance characteristics of
different levels of the memory hierarchy
of a machine that you could build today
so the lowest level is a thread we can
work up to an SM or a core you can have
an entire processor an entire GPU you
can look at the node level you can look
at the rack level for each of these you
have a different total amount of compute
you have a different total amount of
memory capacity and then you have a
different bandwidth and latency x' to
these different these different levels
so an interesting aspect of this that's
already taken advantage of by the fact
that people run models on one GPU at a
time is that you need a certain size of
a model this is different depending on
different types of models so I made a
simplifying assumption here and we're
just using fully connected layers or
recurrent neural network layers for a
convolution these numbers wouldn't be
right but this is just to kind of give
you some intuition basically the idea
here is on the other side of the figure
you see these these blocks so these
represent dense 2d matrices kind of an
approximation of a neural network layer
at the lowest level you would need only
an 8x8 matrix to saturate a single
thread to get full utilization out of a
thread as you move up the memory
hierarchy you need bigger and bigger
layers to fully utilize the machine
there are this is taking into account
all of these constraints real systems
would have even more constraints than
this but this simplified model goes a
long way it's a very it's very easy to
figure out what these sizes would be
with a simplified model like this and
they're not too far off
okay so by the time you get to a GPU
level you might need 500 wide layers or
500 unit layers at a single node level
you might need mm wide layers at a rack
level or you might need almost 10,000
size layers the interesting thing here
is really that people kind of go up to
the size of a network that fits on a GPU
and then they stop part of this is
because they don't have a good software
support for this in order to spread out
your computation even further you have
to think about breaking up individual
linear algebra operations over multiple
nodes and writing you know people for
the longest time have struggled with the
problem of writing maintainable software
that does that but from a technical
perspective and from a performance
perspective it should just work and when
we've built implementations of this it
does work you do get good utilization
the question here is really just how do
you get maintainable software that's
portable from one system to another that
has this ability so I feel like there's
a lot of low-hanging fruit here if
existing framework can solve the
software engineering problem there's a
clear path towards getting good
utilization out of much larger machines
by running larger models let's see so to
some extent you're limited by everything
right so these are the primary
limitation so we're using all of these
aspects here in the performance model to
come up with these numbers the primary
limitations are the memory bandwidth and
something called the amount of reuse so
for each byte of memory or sorry for
yeah for each byte of memory that we
load from whatever the highest level
memory is that needs to fit like maybe
an eight thousand by eight thousand
matrix how many times do we or how many
math operations do we perform on it so
different machine
means yeah it's it's it's really all
these together I think this model this
is referred to as the multi bulk
synchronous parallel model is trying to
drill down all the complexities involved
in this into four numbers for each level
of the memory hierarchy it makes it
tractable to do this kind of with pen
and paper but it's in reality the the
you know there are a lot of other things
that go into this go ahead so within a
node you're using PCI and in between
nodes you're using InfiniBand or
Ethernet and there's just a difference
in bandwidth between those I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry about that that's
definitely a typo on the slide I'll fix
that so they should be nanoseconds yes
that would be frightening okay any other
questions okay these are all theoretical
Peaks on this purpose processor you can
get 80 to 90% of it
okay alright so this is model
parallelism if you had a bigger model
you could run on a lot bigger machine
there's one thing that I didn't really
mention at the very beginning that's
relevant here is that as you get more
data as you have a larger data set you
typically also need a larger model to
absorbant the relationship between these
has come what complicated but you do
generally have this kind of effect there
is an advantage of using bigger models
at large still parallel eyes up if your
model isn't that large can you still use
a machine like this you may be able to
but you probably have to rely primarily
on data parallelism and as we saw
earlier there's a limit to that as well
okay all right let's see
so there's another clear trend I think
towards a lower precision arithmetic
so this this graph is maybe a little bit
hard to read here but the the main point
is we start from a Titan X GPU as a
baseline and all of the points in this
graph represent different types of
models so these are different types of
speech recognition models so from a
theoretical perspective we look at the
expected performance of those models on
different GPUs one graph here represents
a different each graph represents a
different GPU and so the main idea is
that over and to the right right so like
moving over and moving to the right is
better performance so we look at
multiple changes that we could make your
GPU and we're trying to say here given
all the things we could do to our
computer system what change would be the
most important and what would be what
would improve performance the most so we
look at moving from 32-bit
floating-point to 16 bit floating-point
increasing the memory bandwidth from
about 300 gigabytes 2 second to one
terabyte per second doubling the number
of cores doubling the on chip
memory and reducing the off-chip memory
latency by by cutting it in half okay so
the takeaway from this is pretty much
everything helps memory bandwidth helps
the least moving to lower precision
helps the most the reason for this is
you kind of get multiple compounding
effects you get higher throughput in the
same power budget you get basically more
on chip memory capacity effective object
memory capacity because now all of your
waits take less memory to store and they
also take less interconnect bandwidth to
move around your processor so here is
the other side of it however low
precision training is hard so this is
trying to show just some experiments
that we've that we've done and by do on
our speech recognition models training
and in 16-bit precision so the blue
curve here is a training curve using
single precision of a good highly
optimized model the red and the green
version are half precision with no other
modifications than just taking every
single data structure in the whole
network and converting it into half
precision and the orange the orange
graph here is basically sometimes like
looking at each each data structure
individually on a case-by-case basis
flipping some of them over to 16-bit
also when we do math operations like
when we're doing convolutions or matrix
multiply operations we use mixed
precision so we actually there's
actually an effect that we see where if
you use a low precision everywhere you
get these large accumulated errors and
so we want to do most of the math and
low precision and then accumulate into
higher precision in order to not have
these errors become significant over
time so yes you can usually get it to
work we can't we can push it lower all
those hard for us to do these
experiments because to push to lower
precision we have to Emmie
and it's really slow to do these
experiments but usually the process is
you start by flipping everything and
then you know ten things break in
different ways and you have to diagnose
them one by one eventually we get to a
point where we do the vast majority of
the math and in low precision at all
so can we trade precision for the size
of the model I don't think that we've
really done that kind of experiment in a
lot of detail I think there's definitely
an opportunity for more work in this
area maybe sure okay does the does the
error help for regularization so the
solid lines here are the training error
and the dashed lines are the validation
error the reason why there's a gap
between them often is because we added
noise so the training error looks worse
than it actually is so you can see that
you know maybe to some extent like
actually if you look at the blue and the
orange curve here where one is mixed
precision one a single precision the
orange validation here is actually
slightly better it's hard for me to
trust a difference that small but I
think it's possible that you would see a
regularization effect there's a number
of other papers on this on quantize
training and on a paper called dense
sparse dense training that I think shows
an effect like this okay so it's
important to just say what our
perspective is on regularization
regularization is much more important in
a small data regime so in the regime
that we're in where we basically have
infinite data it's not nearly as
important right regularization in the
limit doesn't matter if you look at
every sample only once
so if you have a problem like if you
have a small data set perhaps that would
be very helpful to do this we don't have
a lot of experience or experimental
results here because we're not really
operating in that regime okay all right
let's see so this is this is something
so I've given this talk at a bunch of
places this is the part of the talk that
I usually give to people who build
hardware because commonly the most
important missing piece of hardware is
the software and it's really important
to be able to actually use these like
it's really important if we want to use
like a new hardware with really great
performance characteristics and there's
no software and your hardware is
basically some complicated data flow
malt
you know hugely parallel fine grained
synchronous thing that maybe has great
theoretical performance you know it
would probably take us months or years
to write efficient convolutions
efficient linear algebra operations for
these things so there's a huge amount of
effort involved in that and actually if
you think about it the API surface for
deep learning is actually pretty narrow
you think of things that are narrow like
database operations like sequel as being
like a really narrow interface and it's
really valuable there's a narrow
interface because people don't have to
implement too many different things you
don't need general-purpose C Python
level programming interface to run these
algorithms you really just need Blas
convolutions Malik and mem coffee right
it's a really small interface so Nvidia
did a really great job of actually just
coming out with libraries that work well
and are highly optimized for these
things but it's amazing that these
libraries are missing on a lot of
popular hardware platforms yeah so
however you implement them it's fine
just that's the interface that we use
for these applications all right so the
last part of the talk I want to spend a
few minutes talking about some open
research problems
these are things given the problem setup
given there's a clear value in improving
performance
what are directions that we can go in to
try and there might be promising okay
clearly faster processors would help I
think there a lot of people are you
working on this but I think there is an
important aspect of deep learning where
because we have this power law effect
going on with dataset size and we are
compute limited we don't just want to X
better performance or 4x better
performance we want a thousand X better
we want it to be much much better than
it currently is so it might actually
cause us to fundamentally think about
what are the limits given current
technology if we just went started from
a clean slate what's the best that we
could possibly do you know I've talked
to a bunch of people about this I know
bill Dahle in particular doesn't think
that there's more than a than a 2x
improvement over GPUs and maybe he's
right about that but I think it would be
interesting to consider this and I think
it's also important to think further
into the future if we do have there may
be questions of like well we need like
if you're building computer hardware and
you're saying you know our computer is
really fast enough is my laptop really
fast enough is my cell phone really fast
enough is my cluster really fat already
fast enough maybe it is for a lot of
applications but it's not for deep
learning so let's see how far we can
really go can we actually get to five
nanometers can we actually push further
than that how far does 3d integration
take us there's a clear advantage here
these things have really great deep
neural networks have really great
advantages in terms of the efficiency of
the computational building blocks it's
hard to think of something more
efficient than a convolution from a
computational perspective in terms of
how much data you actually need to move
how much state you actually need to move
around a processor maybe we actually
could build a very tightly integrated 3d
stacked processor with very very low
energy implementing convolutions
okay so there's this interesting effect
so that was faster processors could we
train networks with a sparse
representation we used dense linear
algebra for everything that's the state
of the art could we switch to a sparse
representation would be clear that that
would reduce the total amount of work
that we would do but can we actually get
this to work in practice so you might
think that this is promising because of
work that's been done on taking dents or
taking models that were trained in a
dense fashion and then applying pruning
or quantization to reduce them down into
a sparse representation this has been
done successfully after the model has
already been trained so you get
basically no performance loss in terms
of accuracy for something like a ten to
a hundred times reduction in the total
amount of computational work that you do
moving from a dense to a sparse
representation could we get this to a
work for inference I think to some
extent this is a chicken in the egg and
an egg problem because people really
don't have a lot of motivation to try
getting training to work if hardware and
software libraries harder
implementations and software libraries
can't take advantage of it most of the
time when we actually run sparse
implementations through existing deep
learning frameworks we emulated so it's
actually slower than dense training and
it's very hard to actually do these
experiments and demonstrate a benefit
because what you'd really like to do is
not run the same size model you'd really
like to run a much bigger model or on a
much bigger data set and see if you get
results from training in a sparse
fashion there's also a lot of options
about exactly how you would do this like
how you Rema Tyrael eyes weights you
typically you're thinking of looking at
the space of all functions represented
by representing by a single neural
network and you might think about
constraining that in a way where at a
given point you might materialize only a
certain number of values but you'd like
to have the option of eventually
representing the entire space of
functions it's not really
straightforward to think about how to do
that with the existing algorithms that
people are using you take a gradient you
get you know some step size over all
parameters how do you know which ones to
materialize and which ones not to it's
not really clear but there'd be a big
advantage of someone figured this out
all right I think there's so there's
also this clear limit that we ran into
previously it's different for different
problems we ran into this limit of we
increase the amount of data parallelism
it's one way of scaling to larger
machines but if we do it too much
we eventually make our optimization
algorithm is less efficient so we
converge slower so it begs the question
are there optimization algorithms that
can tolerate more data parallelism more
than SGD I think there are some
experimental results that indicate that
there might be so there's an interesting
effect that people have observed where
when you're trading a model you can
typically increase the batch size over
time without impacting work efficiency
exactly what that effect looks like is
is somewhat hard to measure it's
definitely problem domain specific but I
think effects like that where you can
clearly observe them demonstrate that
there might be some underlying principle
here like if there's some way of
detecting when it's safe to grow the
batch size or whether there's some
optimization algorithm that really isn't
sensitive to this that can average over
larger larger data sets and then in make
better decisions than first order
methods I think there is a possibility
for this but no one's really
demonstrated this yet either all right
so there's also the other side of it
which is take the existing algorithms
they're already amazingly work efficient
let's make them even more efficient so
there is a there may be three common
trends here that have shown promise on
small scale and might scale up to much
her problems so one is hard mining hard
mining is basically looking at your data
set and taking this realization that
some things especially towards the end
of training you're typically just
nailing some examples like some speech
reckon speech recognition some
utterances are just really easy
or maybe envision a vision problem like
maybe pictures of cars are just really
easy and you're having a really hard
time distinguishing between different
breeds of dogs so you can measure the
difficulty when you're training of
individual samples and as you get better
at some of your data set you can shift
your focus towards the things that are
actually harder for you so this is hard
mining curriculum learning tries to do
something similar but isn't really very
dynamic you kind of look at the problem
as a person or using some kind of other
method other than the network and you
trying great examples so you don't want
to start the network with really
difficult problems because it probably
won't be able to find a good solution
randomly start with very easy problems
that work up the harder problems and
active learning basically applies the
same thing to let's see the same kinds
of effects to unsupervised atta so
imagine that you have this large
unlabeled training set you'd let you can
easily do passes of a trained model over
your large unsupervised unlabeled
training depth training set you can use
a model to basically mine through the
large data set and tell you which
examples are the most promising to label
and to add into your data set next so if
you have a fixed computational budget
you can over time iterate through this
multiple times and improve the quality
of your training sets make your learning
more efficient alright so pretty much
getting to the end here hopefully
hopefully I've talked about or convinced
you that there's a lot of promise in
improving performance for deep learning
algorithms that we have a lot of tools
we have a lot of directions that we can
go to make progress here so I want to
leave with a challenge so I've I'm not
entirely sure if this is going to work
so I try
- at some point sit down and say for the
data sets that we have and my
understanding of Technology scaling and
computer architecture
what is the best-case scenario like
absolutely everything perfectly aligns
we invent wonderful new technologies
technologies scaling goes down to like
1/2 of a nanometer
what is the best possible performance
that we could hope to achieve so my
feeling was that it was around 20
petaflop 32 terabytes of RAM at 300
terabytes per second in 3 hundreds this
sounds absolutely insane but deep
learning is an application that could
use this so I want to issue a challenge
to people here to try and build this
system well how much $300 of course yes
of course it has to be cheap how much is
this worth to me I don't know I think
the way I think about this is how much
is it worth to solve speech recognition
to solve computer vision or to solve
language understanding there's no good -
how much is that worth - Society speech
recognition I'm not a business person
unfortunately I think unfortunately
perhaps I wouldn't want to think about
running an operating system on a machine
that was optimized for for running a
neural network that sounds like a way
harder problem than this ok so be happy
to take any questions
anybody's interested in asking me more
questions about this or contacting me be
happy to answer questions please come
visit us at Baidu if you're interested
in learning about more of these topics
this is really just a survey of a few
things we could go a lot more deep into
these topics if you're interested we're
now also hiring we definitely need more
people to work on these problems thank
you
typical deep learning strategies is what
sweat drives is that the cotton what
drives 300 words I think it's just
keeping the existing power power
envelope for a single process or
constant I think there are possibly
thermal limitations and power supply
limitations that might keep you you and
that but if you know if you can improve
performance per watt and you need to
break that assumption okay what is the
network so the question is what is the
network utilization like for
asynchronous assess you need so it
really depends on the model I think for
the speech recognition model is over
about let's say 32 to about 120 ancient
views it's about even without using
asynchronous escheated you know without
using asynchronous SJD we're somewhere
around maybe one gigabyte per second per
link over all the all the PC eiling's
and all of the yum InfiniBand links
somewhere between one and maybe four
gigabytes per second fully utilized does
that make sense I mean you're running it
fairly acceptable even ionisation 100
Gigabit link you're running at 25
percent utilized
the network running at that utilization
doesn't generally especially with more
than incremental updates ensconcing huge
amount of congestion so I'm wondering if
you could turn your argument against
this do you think approach around the
signal you're running at a reasonably
well ization you're not going to see
dramatic effects not really gonna let
somebody come in there and fool with the
pop rate so you know it's really
reasonably stable and then if you see
not record reproducibility with your
model you're runnin that mo and then
there's some instability that you're
gonna see in practice because you're
taking a training day to your training
this stuff it's not gonna see the same
inputs and realities so it's unstable
there and what you're doing then it's
probably fundamentally unstable results
I see so the the question is imagine in
this situation you're not interconnector
limited so if you are using an
asynchronous method you're unlikely to
see non determinism and so that thing is
really unstable right I'm the errors of
your introduced or and there's already a
lot of errors between your training
thank you sure so one way to think about
this per house could be that the
asynchronous method is they're really
only useful if you are out that
interconnect limit for the speech
recognition models we typically don't
use them because we're not near that
limited so there's no maybe there's no
arm but there's also no benefit to using
those methods if you want to introduce
to you know stochasticity into your
training you can do that with random
like explicit resources of random number
generation model initialization or
training set traversal so I definitely
do agree with you that it is a good idea
to introduce some amount of randomness
in training to make sure that the model
is your boss let's say so but this this
statement that the speech recognition
models are not sensitive to here
bandwidth at least at the skills were
running them right now this doesn't
apply to all models so language models
and translation models in particular are
running at the interconnect limit
they're limited by interconnect
bandwidth even given the types of
systems that we have the reason for that
is because they're typically unrolled
they're less computer intensive so they
do less computation for every sample so
there's a whole range of models and this
is really just a tool I shouldn't think
of it as always wanting to use this but
use the difference appropriate all right
so the question is are there differences
in network bandwidth utilization over
time so it's generally possible if you
have a model that's very well balanced
or like a model that if given the
computation as we're given the network
bandwidth then and there are about
equally balanced it's generally possible
to schedule things although it's
difficult so that they're perfectly
overlapped you never get perfect overlap
but you can get pretty high overlap that
being said it's hard to do that I think
most frameworks don't do this basically
in large layers there's just a lot of
parallelism so you can think about all
of the model waves and especially during
that propagation you can think of
backpropagation as exposing some of the
weights as being available or for
synchronization so you can kind of
overlap
if you break things up in to find enough
pieces you can overlap synchronize these
weights do back propagation before the
next set of waves and kind of cascade
that through the entire network as long
as you can schedule with things like
that you have a global visibility into
the whole problem you can usually
overlap thing as well
that being said if you're unbalanced
right like for different models you
might have different interconnects to
compute ratios if you swing it very far
on one end of the spectrum or another it
will be limited by the one of the other
so you swing from like they're very
compute limiting you'll swing from
phases where you're doing just all
compute and then a little bit of
bandwidth or if your network eliminate
your swing from phase three during all
networks just a little bit of computer
if you're not sensitive to these things
like if you're not actually working at
the characteristic of your system it's
very common that you'll just end up in
one of those team situations it's a
really it's an important point actually
that there's a big space of models
there's us and there's a smaller space
that works well for given application
for speech recognition and revision
there's an even smaller set that runs
efficiently on heartland
you